the United Nations has raised alarm over
the unprecedented food crisis in
southern Africa 45 million people face
severe shortages according to the World
Food Program years of drought widespread
flooding and economic turmoil are being
blamed for the emergency the 16
countries in the region have had a
normal crop season only once in the last
five years
Zimbabwe is the worst hit with seven
point seven million people that's half
the population suffering severe food
shortages and one-fifth of the
population in Zambia a regional
breadbasket is struggling to feed itself
gerald bork is the spokesperson for the
World Food Programme for southern Africa
he joins us now live from Johannesburg
good to have you with us
jerem is this a new product problem I
mean I'm surely you know as we said
years of drought and widespread flooding
and economic turmoil are being blamed
for this current emergency when when did
it start
well it's it's an annual problem every
year between harvests and there is
basically a single harvest in a given
year the harvest typically comes in in
April May and as stocks from the
previous harvest run down people get
hungrier so we are now at the peak of
the lean season but the numbers are
unprecedented at 45 million is a record
so it is a crisis of dramatic
proportions all right so what's it gonna
take to fix it money I suppose
absolutely the world food programs
operation that runs until the next
harvest in in April May costs 500
million dollars we have secured just two
hundred million dollars of that so we
need pledges urgently because it can
take weeks if not months for a financial
commitment to translate into food on the
ground sure because so much of Africa
has been so hard hit by drought and
flooding this year we have to procure
very far afield so there are very long
lead times between procurement ship
and arrival of food in country you say
you need you need pledges from whom
gerald
well governments business individuals
even but typically much of the money
that WFP collects for crises like these
come from national governments so we
need them to step up step in very
quickly what are the prospects then of
getting this sorted in time for what
what you said April May absolutely time
is running out as I say because it can
take weeks if not months to procure and
ship the food we really do need those
commitments very urgently people are
struggling they are destitute families
are down to one meal a day if even that
they're taking their children out of
school they're selling off what little
they have by way of precious belongings
they're borrowing money and going into
debts so it's it's a crisis of many
dimensions and it is getting worse I
should also say that you mentioned the
fact that the region has had one normal
rainy season in the last five years the
weather forecasts are telling us that in
the run-up to the next harvest it is
going to continue to be exceptionally
hot exceptionally dry so the prospects
are for yet another poor harvest in
southern Africa this year Jared good to
talk to you many thanks indeed for being
with us Cheryl book that the spokesman
for the World Food Programme for
Southern Africa